feel that way we understand others who
may have been in contact with those
congressmen are now self quarantine II
dr. deborah birx is a response
coordinator for the white house corona
virus task force and she joins us now
from Washington dr. Burks thank you for
taking the time I know your plate is
overflowing but I want to refer to
weisia to Jennings piece where we heard
the president say we are going to win
and we will win very quickly what is the
White House definition of quickly I
think we're all looking very closely at
the data the data coming out of China
the data coming out of South Korea we're
encouraged by the recent reports from
China of no new cases we're very
watching very carefully about China
going back to work and seeing it that
impacts the the spread of the virus so
we're learning from other countries if
our profile looks like China we believe
that that is very quickly but if we're
evaluating every single country and the
data coming from that country dr. Burks
I think Americans can handle just about
anything but they do need to know what
to expect you mentioned China as a
possible timeline right now we're in
this two weeks to slow the spread period
but there are other reports coming from
the administration about a possible
18-month fight how long should Americans
be prepared to take precautions to fight
this pandemic you know that's a great
question on the models not only looked
at what's happening during this current
outbreak but you know with respiratory
diseases they have a peak and often fall
off during the summer months if this
works like every other respiratory
disease that comes to us in the winter
then we're tracking very carefully about
what would happen it would have came
back in the fall or came back in the
fall after that and that's why the
president's been working nonstop both on
therapeutics that could be available in
the summer and fall and vaccines that
could be available in the fall of 2020
so it's a long it's a just a two-day
vision a tomorrow vision but also a
90-day vision a fall vision and a fall
2021 vision to make sure that we're
following everything at this point when
do you anticipate the peak to be well
the only thing we can look at is the
same thing you all are looking at is
what the peaks look like in every other
country now in every other country where
the peak came and the cases
declined it was because every single
person in that country followed the
guidelines that our president has put
out these guidelines are extraordinarily
important it's about social distancing
it's about washing your hands it's about
ensuring that you're protecting yourself
and protecting others it's not about
partying on beaches during spring break
so dr. Burks what concerns you most at
this point I think the rapid nosov the
getting our own data I think that's very
important we applaud the legislation for
putting in the White House requests for
reporting I think we need to see a
hundred percent of the cases I know a
lot of people are looking at the data
that came out of the MMWR to some
morning the numbers are not large enough
for us to make conclusions from but as
we've always been worried about
individuals with pre-existing conditions
in every age group so we're asking every
hospital every clinic to report both
their testing results and their outcomes
at the hospitalization can you give us
an update on the testing how many cases
are out there how many more do you need
when you take the test how long does it
take to get the results people are very
concerned about the testing that's an
excellent question because what happened
with the testing before we could get the
high speed laboratory commercial labs up
and running is there was a backlog and
so to every Americans out there that's
washing watching the new cases these are
new cases coming from the backlog for
samples that were collected four five
and six days ago and as those get run
our number of new cases will
dramatically increase because they're
not daily cases their cases that are
come from the last few days once we get
through the backlog will be able to tell
you precisely how many tests are
negative how many are positive and with
this new reporting requirement it will
be accurate dr. Burks thank you very
much we appreciate you being with us